The Joe Rogan Experience I think we
talked about this before in relation to
the Communist era in Eastern Europe that
that sort of part of the point that
you the humiliation of going along with
things you know aren't true ends up
having an effect down the road because
you just nod anything along
yeah I have a friend who grew up Mormon
and one thing she said to me once was
really interesting she said uh because
she left the church and she said I'm I'm
really susceptible to [ __ ] it's a
real problem wow and so she started like
she had gotten mixed up with some like
Yogi type people and Guru type people
right people that were running like
these weird little sort of like
self-help things that were very
cult-like and she goes I have a real
problem I'm very susceptible she goes
because I I grew up
agreeing to things that are nonsensical
and because of that because I had just
like given all of my you know what when
you when you just like all of your
opinions are decided by a church and the
church is written by a 14 year old boy
in 1820 yeah like it's it's kind of nuts
yeah and that already had a conviction
for fraud yeah he was already full of
[ __ ] at 14.
that was a giveaway yeah that was a
definite giveaway well it's I mean the
just if you read the tenets of the
religion first of all they're wonderful
people Mormons yeah I agree I agree I
don't like beating up on Mormons because
they're so nice yeah it's like actually
if if there were more Mormons right it
wouldn't be it was so bad you know if
you could just take out the crazy yeah
you got a good religion yeah
um I uh wow how much crazy anyway
um but that's it's sort of the same
principle sort of applies to when people
just accept you know like with wokism
except except these ideological Givens
that aren't logical they don't make any
sense I wonder if it's the same with
societies you know I think that uh
it's a thing like post-religious peoples
just because you've lost the religion
doesn't mean you've lost the religious
Instinct right you're still looking for
it it seems like that's an inherent part
of being a person I agree and I I don't
think I don't say it's bad it's just it
is part of what we are and uh it seems
to me very clear that for instance you
know you take Christianity out and other
things will be put in and they don't
even need to be identifiable religions
right uh I mean our own age has decided
in much of the West that there's this
sort of form of uh watered-down
spillover of Christianity which will
become the sort of religion which is the
kind of diversity inclusion Equity world
where you constantly struggle for
greater Justice all of which is a sort
of very watered-down version of a little
bit of Christianity there's a clear
Genesis of that too in the the woke
World there was a a group at a certain
point in time do you remember when the
atheist movement had hit this atheist
plus movement do you remember atheism
plus what was that it was weird and it
was a bunch of these weird virtue
signaling male feminist types that were
added thing with atheism adding a a
group of core values oh what about you
know being
anti-discrimination
anti-sexist
anti-racist their own Ten Commandments
yes and so they they called it atheism
plus and I remember watching this guy
give this speech this [ __ ] boring
speech on this
sort of establishing this
this idea that because you don't have a
religion
um so we're going to be atheists but
with plus we can establish sort of a
moral framework well it's totally
understandable uh and a disaster of
course and most
um even if the ideas are good it's like
you're putting it in an ideology you're
creating a dog you're creating all those
new atheists who sort of started on the
2000 I got friends Sam Harris and others
they in my experience they all got a
little bit nervous about the what was on
their shoulders Christopher Hitchens
certainly did he started I think
laterally in his life to get a little
bit nervous about what was happening I
remember once asking him what what about
he said people were starting to ask him
to officiate at their weddings oh yeah
and that was like he he didn't say
anything of what he said was wrong he
still obviously believed everything he
believed but like that's a slightly
troubling
place to be in because you start to
sense people are wanting you to replace
the vicar or the priest and that's and
that's not the point then you're in Life
of Brian territory aren't you like you
know I want you know you should all
think for yourselves yes we all think
for ourselves it's it it was always a
problem of atheism was like it was an
invitation to
to not do one thing yeah but it didn't
but nothing follows from it as to how
you should live your life and
if it's the start of something it's not
by any means a beginning of a policy do
you think that's just an inherent
thing about being a tribal primate that
we have this desire to have someone
wiser a leader and then even better if
you can have like a god-like figure who
gives you a set of rules that you have
to follow or they're horrendous
consequences and it keeps everyone in
line yeah absolutely I always
um in the 2000s I started to think if
somebody came along and declared
prophethood at the moment
well they could do quite well
uh I mean think of those those hostesses
on U.S television who still
still take money from people saying that
they can only build the church and have
their helicopter if you send in your
dollars you know uh those people still
exist there's a guy who's still selling
his like silver water that He blesses
from the River Jordan or something it
comes out some hose of its Garden in
Texas you know yeah and there are people
who've been busted repeatedly and
they're still uh they're still selling
their Wares
um I I always thought yeah if somebody
actually made the profit claim in our
era I think people would be surprised
how many people would go along with it
it's what is the late George Steiner
um described a phrase I love the
Nostalgia for the absolute
I love that phrase a Nostalgia for the
absolute I think I think a lot of people
have it I have it we all have it to some
extent and the question is whether you
can avoid it taking you to places that
um would demoralize you and lead you to
a bad place
yeah it's
I think
if someone came along and had a really
good cult like a real solid cult like
really welled out well laid out be
rational think for yourself be kind
examine all evidence like people join
into that and then it would it always
ends up with like a massive orgy doesn't
it yes it does it always said something
you got to give me all your money
exactly like wild wild country it's like
oh it's all about peace and it's like
nah now you got a school of women wild
wild country is amazing that documentary
is so good I love that that Osho had
some really interesting you still see
his um books in some places like in the
Netherlands they had his books still in
the Bookshop so you could buy them on
Apple on on the Apple bookstore I've
read a couple of them I do like that bit
where he says he says in one of his
speeches he says the people people are
[ __ ]
by the people for the people of the
people but the problem is the people are
[ __ ]
it should be by the [ __ ] for the
[ __ ] it's like oh my God a guru is
saying that and it's something about the
fact that he's dead now and then yeah he
said it decades ago it's like but we are
fine we are searching for for things at
the moment yeah it seems very obvious to
me I mean that is you know what plenty
of people have called them like things
like the religion of anti-racism the
religion of social justice all that
stuff
they are all something to do you know
yes uh some very very deep level like
you've had your purpose today like
you've had your five fruit and veg you
had your meaning yeah you've had your
meaning